britney spears addressed the court on
wednesday
in her ongoing conservatorship case
here's what she said
britney appeared via an audio conference
called to address judge brenda penny
about her wishes to remove her father
jamie as conservator
of her estate britney spoke for nearly
20 minutes
saying she wants the conservatorship to
end claiming she was forced to work
against her will and compared the
situation
to human trafficking brittany told the
court she wants to sue her family for
alleged abuses
including being sent to a facility over
a disagreement during rehearsals in 2019
for her second vegas residency which of
course
was ultimately canceled one of the
biggest testimony bombshells
britney says she's been forced to wear
an iud so she can't get pregnant
and that the conservatorship won't let
her marry boyfriend sam askari
as you'll remember back in 2008
brittany's dad jamie spears
filed for a temporary conservatorship
after concerns over his daughter's
mental health
a decision that was granted and later
became permanent
and in late 2020 brittany requested to
suspend her father as her
conservatorship
as her conservator which was denied at
the time the singer's lawyer said that
she is afraid of her father
and that she may not perform again as
long as her father is in charge of her
career
earlier this year in march brittany's
lawyer requested the resignation of
jamie as her permanent conservator
and asked that jodie montgomery
brittany's professional care manager
replaced her dad as the sole conservator
and that brings us to today
brittany being granted permission to
address the court directly
a source tells e.t that brittany has
been quote looking forward to this day
for a long time and that she felt 100
percent ready
to address the court ahead of brittany's
statement et spoke to legal expert
rachel stockman
who said she doesn't think britney's
speaking out will affect the outcome of
the hearing negatively
i mean i don't think it's necessarily a
big deal in your
average conservatorship hearing if the
conservative decides to speak out
however
this is not your average case this is
involving a huge celebrity
so i think it's a very big deal that
she's speaking out and
she has told the court she wants her
voice heard i certainly
think the tension with her father and
all that's happened over the last few
years and these
various incidences that have occurred
has really
fed into why she feels like she needs to
speak out now
i think it wouldn't be surprising if her
father is removed if we slowly start to
see her
taking the stage again and going into
the public eye
meanwhile brittany's boyfriend of nearly
five years sam posted a photo of himself
wearing a free britney t-shirt with a
lion
representing his nickname for brit
lioness this is just
hours before her hearing our source adds
she is doing this with complete support
from sam
and that he has stood by her throughout
brittany and sam of course met on the
set of her 2016 music video for slumber
party
and he has been vocal about wanting
change for brittany
in february sam took to instagram to
call out britney's dad jamie writing
now it's important for people to
understand that i have zero respect for
someone trying to control our
relationship
and constantly throwing obstacles our
way
in a report published tuesday by the new
york times the outlet claimed that
britney has been trying to end the
conservatorship since as early as 2014
but records of her requests were sealed
and unavailable to the public
however in those documents as reported
by the times brittany
called the legal guardianship an
oppressive and controlling tool against
her
and claimed that it controlled
everything from who she dated
to the color of her kitchen cabinets
after calling for a recess jamie spears
legal team returned to the hearing and
told the court that
he is sorry to hear his daughter in so
much pain mr
spears loves and misses his daughter
very much
britney's representation then told the
judge that the superstar is fine with
all
future hearings being sealed moving
forward meaning we're unlikely to hear
from brittany in court again
when it comes to her conservatorship her
lawyer also says he will meet with
brittany to discuss her options
when it comes to ending the
conservatorship
et's lauren zema is at the courthouse
and she got a chance to speak to the
director of the new york times doc
framing britney spears
which of course sparked renewed interest
in brittany's case
here's what she told us about why the
influence of the lawyers is
likely the reason it's been so long for
action to be taken
with someone who's been working on this
so closely you know all the players in
this game
what does that say to you about the
lawyers here brittany's lawyer
especially
i mean i think we really have to look
really hard at this conservatorship
system and the conflict of interest
in a you know a person not being able to
choose their own lawyer being
represented by someone
you know chosen by the court who is
making money as long as she's in the
conservatorship
you